Pour ne louper aucune vidéo, abonnez-vous
et activez la petite cloche.
Le 17 janvier c'est mon anniversaire !
Ça tombe bien ça fait très longtemps
que j'ai envie devous parler de bougies.
Comment elles brûlent,
ce qu'ilsecache à l'intérieur de la flamme.
Il fait pas chaud ici, à l'intérieur il fera
meilleur !
Il manque quelques bougies mais
c'est que le gâteau n'était pas assez grand.
Ah, çaaussi c'est une question
qu'on se pose souvent
"Pourquoi certaines bougies
se rallument-elles toutesseules ?"
Avant de vous donner la réponse,
un peu d'histoire.
Même s'il est difficile de faire
lapart des choses,
le gâteau d'anniversaire
avec les bougies plantées dedans
est une tradition
relativement récente.
On aurait commencé à les souffler
au début du 19e siècle en Allemagne.
Dansun texte, datant de 1802,
Goethe le célèbre poète allemand
fait référence à la fête organisée
pourses 53 ans au milieu des gâteaux et des bougies.
Il faut dire qu'autrefois, on fêtait rarement les
anniversaires jusqu'à la fin du Moyen-Âge au moins
l'état civil n'existe pas. Il ne sera instauré
qu'après la révolution, les gens ne connaissent
donc pas leur date de naissance. À l'époque, on
parle plutôt des différentes périodes de la vie :
la jeunesse, l'âge mûr et la vieillesse.
Le refrain qui accompagne
l'événement...
est beaucoup plus récent.
La partition a été composéen 1893
et les paroles "happy birthday to you"
ajoutées en 1924.
Joyeux anniversaire, nos vœux les
plus sincères !
Quand à la version française,
elle date de 1951.
On fête donc, cette année,
ses 70ans.
À l'origine les bougies sont fabriquées
avec de la cire d'abeille.
La cire avec laquelle
ellesfabriquent leurs alvéoles,
dans lesquelles elles vont stocker le miel.
Cette cire est prélevée dans
les ruches.
Le mot bougie vient d'ailleurs du nom
de la ville Bedjaïa en Algérie
qui, autrefois,exportait de grandes
quantités de cire d'abeilles vers l'Europe.
Depuis le début 20ème siècle,
la plupart des bougies est fabriquée
à partir de paraffine.
Il s'agit d'une cire minérale
dérivée dupétrole.
On trouve également des bougies
produites avec de la cire végétale
issue du colza ou dusoja.
Mais quelle que soit l'origine de la cire,
toutes les bougies sont fabriquées
de lamême manière,
suivant le même procédé :
la mèche est installée
dès le départ dans un moule,
puis on coule de la cire tout autour
de cette mèche
et voici le résultat.
Certaines bougies sont
encore fabriquées à la plonge,
la mèche est trempée dans un bain
de cire chaude et liquide
On la retire, on attend que la cire
refroidisse et qu'elle se fige,
puis on renouvelle l'opération.
À chaque plongeon, la bougie
prend du volume.
Elle me fait craquer celle ci.
Alors la flamme
d'une bougie, ça paraît tout simple
et pourtant c'est un phénomène
physique extrêmement complexe.
"Toutes les lois de l'univers se manifestent
dans la combustion d'une bougie"
disait Michael Faraday, le célèbre physicien
anglais au 19e siècle,
plus connu pour ses travaux sur l'électricitéet
l'inventeur notamment de la cage de Faraday.
Je vous éclaire.
Sous l'effet de la chaleur, la cire
se met à fondre.
Devenue liquide, elle remonte dans
la mèche en coton par capillarité,
exactement
comme le fait le café dans le sucre.
C'est ce qu'on appelle un canard.
Et c'est bon !
Toujourssous l'effet de la chaleur,
la cire se vaporise
et se mélange à l'air ambiant.
On se retrouvealors, avec les trois ingrédients
indispensables à la combustion,
ce qu'on appelle le triangle dufeu.
Le combustible, c'est la cire,
le comburant, c'est l'air,
et l'énergie, la chaleur apportée
par la flamme.
Sous l'effet de cette chaleur, le mélange
cire/air s'enflamme et entretientle phénomène.
La bougie continue à briller.
Une flamme qui cache d'ailleurs
très bien son jeu.
Contrairement à l'idée que nous en faisons,
une flamme ne forme pas un cône plein.
C'est seulementune enveloppe.
À la base, on distingue une zone bleue
la température atteint ici 1200 degrés,
lacombustion est complète.
Il n'y a pas de déchet ou presque,
de l'eau et du dioxyde de carbone,
lefameux "CO2".
Au-dessus, la flamme devient jaune,
la température atteint 1500 degrés,
la combustionest incomplète,
il y a plus de paraffine, plus de cire
et moins d'air, moins d'oxygène.
Unegrande partie a été utilisé
au niveau de la zone bleue.
Il se forme alors des composés
à basede carbone,
vous savez, les fameuses suies,
ces particules noires
qui s'accumulent au
dessus de la flamme.
On s'en passerait bien et bien non !
Car ce sont ces particules qui,chauffées à blanc,
rayonnent et produisent de la lumière.
Alors quand on prive la bougie
d'un deces éléments,
l'oxygène, la chaleur ou la cire,
elle s'éteint.
C'est exactement ce qu'il se passe
quand on la recouvre.
L'oxygène contenu dans le volume d'air brûle
et la flamme n'est plusalimentée
en comburant,
elle s'éteint.
Attention !
Si vous faites l'expérience chez vous,
la présenced'un adulte est indispensable.
On ne joue pas avec le feu.
Et quand on souffle dessus,
que sepasse-t-il ?
Quand on souffle sur la bougie
on repousse la flamme,
la température autourde la mèche diminue
et la combustion s'arrête.
D'ailleurs, si à ce moment là,
vous approchez uneflamme
de la fumée qui se dégage
de la mèche,
comme ceux ci.
Le mélange s'enflamme à nouveau,
redescend jusqu'à la mèche
qui se met à brûler.
Mais pourquoi certaines se rallument ?
Et oui, comme celle-ci !
C'est parce qu'on n'y a rajouté un élément,
en général du magnésium
dont lepoint de combustion, autrement dit
la température à laquelle elle s'enflamme
est inférieure à celle
de la paraffine.
Du coup, quand on souffle sur la flamme,
la chaleur résiduelle dans la mèche suffit
à enflammer le magnésium contenu dans les gaz,
la température monte,
et la bougie se rallume.
C'estmagique !
Bon allez, il faut que je vous laisse,
la petite caméra s'impatiente.
Faut que j'aille souffler mes bougies
pour manger le gâteau.
Et joyeux anniversaire à tous ceux
qui sont nés le 17 janvier.
Le 18.
Le 19.
Le 20.
Et à la tienne Etienne !
à bientôt !
Au dessus de la flamme,
ces petitesparticules noires,
Ah ba zut ! C'est éteint
Là, je sens que je vous enfume !